اثامنا بتوقيت جريناش الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياضه انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
بعد ان اقتربت من موسكو مسيرته اوكرانيا
تشن هجوما على القرم وروسيا تشدد الرقبه
على الحدود والحركه الجويه
قائد القياده المركزيه للجيش الاسرائيلي
يعترف بان عنف المستوطنين في بلده حواره
في نابلس كان مجزره منظمه
العربيه في مخيم الهول ترصد الاوضاع
الامنيه فيه بعد اكتشاف نشاط واضح لخلايا
التنظيم بداخله
لا تعض اليد التي تطعمك بهذه الكلمات
الصين تهاجم ايلون ماسك وتهدده بتسلا
والسبب تغريدات ماسك حول اصل كورونا
[موسيقى]
وصلت موقعتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
رقعه القتال تتسع شيئا فشيئا في اوكرانيا
لتشمل حتى الاراضي الروسيه على ما يبدو في
اخر التطورات قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان اوكرانيا شنت هجوما كبيره بطائرات
مسيره على شبه جزيره القرم وبلغ عدد
الطائرات التي تم بها الهجوم 10 مسيرات
تمكنت من اسقاطها القوات الروسيه التي
قالت انها نجحت في صاد الهجوم الذي لم
يتسبب في ايه اضرار هجوم طرح السؤال حول
اما اذا كانت اوكرانيا تنوي البدء في شن
هجمات على الاراضي الروسيه وهو ما كان
نفاه مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه من خيلو
ودونياك
الكرملين رد على هذه التصريحات بانه لا
يصدق بيان الرئاسات الاوكرانيه بشان
مهاجمه مناطق في روسيا وذلك بعدما صرح
المستشار ميخايلو بودياك بان اوكرانيا لا
تهاجم مناطق في روسيا وكان مسؤولون روس
قالوا ان اوكرانيا حاولت اطلاق سلسله
هجمات بالطائرات من دون الطيار على
الاراضي الروسيه
وهجوم اوكرانيا هذا على شبه جزيره القرم
بالمسيرات لم يكن الوحيد تقول موسكو بل ان
هناك هجوما اوكرانيا غير مسبوق بطائرات
مسيره وصل الى اطراف العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو في واقعه غير مسبوقه منذ اندلاع
الحرب قبل عام تقول وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
الرئيس روسيا فلاديمير بوتين دخل على الخط
حيث وجه اوامره بتكثيف النشاط الامني
والاستخباراتي في مواجهه التهديدات
الجديده وقال ان بلاده سوف ترد بكل
الوسائل على اي خطر يتهدد امنها القومي
وتواترت معلومات حول تعرض مناطق في روسيا
لهجمات بمسيارات اوكرانيه ايضا واعلنت
السلطات الروسيه ان ثلاثه مسيرات اوكرانيه
تم اسقاطها في شوارع مدينه بلكروده
الروسيه ما الحق بعض الاضرار بنوافذ
المنازل والسيارات في تلك المناطق كما
اعلنت القوات الروسيه عن التصدي لجسم طائر
سقط في منطقه
لكن الحادثه الاكثر لفتا للانظار تمثلت في
اعلان الاسقاط الاعلان عن اسقاط مسيره في
بلده كولومنا على اطراف العاصمه الروسيه
لتكون المره الاولى التي تعلن فيها موسكو
وصولها هجمات مماثله الى العاصمه الروسيه
تحدث زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي عن اهميه انتصار اوكرانيا والدعم
الامريكي لها ومواقف اصدقاء الولايات
المتحده الاخيره تجاه اوكرانيا
اصدقائنا وشركائنا في الشرق الاوسط كان
عليهم ان يواصلوا التعامل مع روسيا كقوه
مؤثره في المنطقه منذ ان فشل الرئيس
اوباما في فرض خطه الاحمر في سوريا
واندفاع الرئيس بوتين الى هذا الصراع الان
يرى شركائنا نفس القذائف الايرانيه
والطائرات بدون طياره التي ضربت مدنهم
وتستخدمها روسيا لمهاجمه اوكرانيا انهم
يعلمون ان موسكو ستكافئ طهران قريبا
وستكون روسيا المنتصره اقل تقييدا في
توفير القدرات المتقدمه لايران
وبينما تتواصل المعارك في مختلف الجبهات
في اوكرانيا تزداد حاجه كياب الى الاسلحه
الغربيه وان كانت تتدفق بشكل متواصل من
جهات متعدده حاجيه الجيش الاوكراني ما
فتئت تتزايد منذ بدايه الحرب حيث باتت
اوكرانيا تتطلع الى الحصول على مقاتله اف
16 من الولايات المتحده واشنطن من جهادها
نزلت لم تحسم قرارها بعد بخصوص تسليم
الطائرات جلسات الامريكيه شهدت مناقش
متواصله بين عدد من النواب ومسؤولين
بوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه حول ارسال
مقاتلات اف 16 الى كييف ونقلت صحيفه
نيويورك ان بعض اعضاء مجلس النواب
الامريكي من الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
يطالبون بتزويد اوكرانيا
لكن ارسال طائرات الاف سته عشر الى
اوكرانيا يصطدم بعراقيل عديده قد تجعل
الخطوه غير فعاله اولى هذه العقبات هي
المده الطويله التي يتطلبها التدريب على
استخدام المقاتلات والتي قد تصل الى 18
شهرا كما
ان في القديمه يتطلب في افضل الاحوال مده
تصل الى 18 شهرا اما شراء وتسليم طائرات
جديده فقد يستغرق ما يصل الى ست سنوات دون
ان ننسى التكلفه المرتفعه للطائرات
وعواءات اخرى من قبيل الحاجه الى تدريب
الميكانيكيين وتوفير مهابط تستوعب هذه
الطائرات فضلا عن امتلاك قطع غيار
للمقاتلات
لكن المؤيدين لفكره تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمقاتلات يشددون على انها ستساعدك كثيرا
في المعارك حيث ستمكنها من استهداف انظمه
صواريخ الدفاع الجوي الروسيه وتتوفر هذه
الطائرات على الكترونيات متطوره للغايه
قادره على الوصول الى اهداف دقيقه وتاتي
كل هذه التطورات بينما لم يتغير لحد الان
موقف الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن من تسليم
المقاتلات لاوكرانيا حيث قال في اخر تصريح
بخصوص الموضوع ان الرئيس الاوكراني لا
يحتاج الى هذه الطائرات حاليا
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل تسير نحو اتخاذ قرار متشدد على
خلفيه الهجمات الفلسطينيه الاخيره في
اسرائيل ويتعلق الامر بمشروع قانون صادق
عليه الكنيست الاسرائيلي يتيح اعدام
الفلسطينيين منفذي الهجمات ضد اسرائيل ومن
المقرر ان يمر القانون بثلاث قراءات اخرى
في الكنيست حتى يصبح قانونا نافذا
ردود الفعل انتقد مركز عداله وهو المركز
القانوني لحقوق الاقليه العربيه في
اسرائيل انتقد مشروع القانون بعد المصادقه
عليه وقال المركز ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه
من خلال هذا القرار تعمل على تعزيز وجود
نظامين قضائيين مختلفين على اساس العرق
واحد لليهود واخر للفلسطينيين كما اعتبر
المركز مشروع القانوني هذا بانه غير
اخلاقي ويناقض القانون الدولي وقوانين
الاساس ويندرج في اطار التشريعات التي
تهدف الى تعزيز نظام مع ملامح
مسؤول عسكري اسرائيلي بارز ان حلقه عشرات
السيارات والمنازل الذي قام به مستوطنون
يهود متطرفون في بلده في بلده فلسطينيه
كان مجزره المنظمه واضاف قائد القياده
المركزيه لجيش الاسرائيلي ان الجيش لم يكن
مستعدا للعنف الذي ظهر بهذا الحجم في بلده
حواره في نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
ما حدث في حواره مذبحه منظمه من خارجين عن
القانون ننشر قواتنا قدر استطاعتنا بعد كل
هجوم هناك ظاهره من خارجين عن القانون
يذهبون الى مفترقه الطرق ويرشقون بالحجاره
ويقطعون ممرات فلسطينيه كنا مستعدين لمثل
هذا الفعل وحتى اكثر منه لكن لم نكن
جاهزين لمذبحه بهذا الحجم وهذا العدد من
الاشخاص
وما تزال قوات الامن الاسرائيليه تجري
عمليات بحث ومطارده خلف منافذ عمليه اطلاق
النار في بلده حوار جنوب نابلس بدايه
الاسبوع الحالي التي لا مقتل مستوطنين
اثنين فيما يمنع اصحاب المحل التجاريه على
الشارع الرئيسي من فتح ابواب محالهم او
ازاله اثار الدمار من داخل المحل التي
احترقت بفعل هجوم المستوطنين
ابو احمد وبعد مرور ثلاثه ايام يتفقد اثار
الدمار الذي لحق بممتلكاته جراء هجوم
المستوطنين عليها بدايه الاسبوع خلال
البوابه فات من هون يعني
كسروا السياره وحركوها
السياره وحركوها
احنا كنا فوق طبعا وممنوع حدا ينزل وممنوع
او بطخ علينا دموع وقنابل صوت
وجيش احتلال بحرصهم كان الجنود وهاي
الواجهه اتطلع كيف كله كله على النار
واحنا سبعه وجوا الدار عندي خمس اولاد خمس
اطفال عندي احنا السبعه محصورين فوق
عشرات المركبات والمنشات احرقت وتركت
خلفها كم من الخوف وعدم الشعور بالامان قد
لا تستطيع جهود التضامن والدعم تبديده
حديثنا عن حمايه دوليه اشبعنا كلام اذا لم
نكن نحن بحمايه اهلنا واعتقد انه اللجان
الشعبيه هي الرد الحقيقي على كل ما يقوم
به المستوطنين من عربدي وغير ذلك المجتمع
الدولي يكتب تقارير المجتمع الدولي يدين
المجتمع الدولي يستنكر ولكن بالمجمل العام
حان الوقت انه احنا شعبيا نتصدى
للمستوطنين
حواره اشبهوا بمدينه اشباح يخيم عليها
الصمت والحزن كما يمنع الجيش الاسرائيلي
اصحاب المحل التجاريه من فتح ابوابها حجم
الدمار على الارض ورائحه الحرائق في
المكان تدل على حجم الخوف الذي عاشته هذه
البلده قبل ثلاثه ايام وعلى حجم قله
الحيله في توفير الحمايه للمدنيين
الفلسطينيين من بلده حواره شمال الضفه
الغربيه خالد القاسم العربيه
اتابع من القدس مع مراسل العربيه زياد
حلبي زياد اهلا بك معنا
تحدث هذا المساء قبل قليل صحيح ان يتحدث
عن الاحتجاجات الداخليه ضد قانون اصلاح
القضاء ولكنه عرج على حواره اهم ما قاله
نتنياهو هذا المساء زياد
الواضح بانه تحت وضع الضغط شديد بفعل ان
الشارع الان بات بشكل واضح يضغط على هذه
الحكومه بسبب ملفات ملف اضعاف القضاء او
الانقلاب على نظام القضاء في اسرائيل
ولهذا نتنياهو عمليا حاول ان يتهم
المعارضه اساسا بمحاوله التسبب بالفوضى
داخل اسرائيل وربما ضرب مثلا فيما حدث في
حواره وانه عارض عمليا اخذ القانون
بايديهم يقصد المستوطنين فيما ان وزراء
وزراء بارزوه بارزين في الحكومه ايدوا هذه
العمليه بشكل او باخر اليوم وزير الماليه
قال يجب ان تدمر حوار عن بكره ابيها وطبعا
سمعنا الخارجيه الامريكيه انتقدت وطلبت
نتنياهو بان يخرج علنا ضد هذه
التصريحات
الواضح ان ازمه عميقه الان في اسرائيل
وبدات تؤثر في اكثر من اتجاه على الامن
وعلى العلاقات الدوليه الاسرائيليه وداخل
اسرائيل هذه الازمه الداخليه في اسرائيل
وشكل الحكومه الاسرائيليه وهذه التصريحات
التي نسمعها واضافه طبعا الى الاقتحامات
والاحداث التي حصلت مؤخرا كيف تنعكس زياده
على الوضع الميداني وضع الضفه المناطق
والمدن العربيه كذلك هناك مدن الفلسطينيه
والمناطق الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه على
راسها طبعا حوار التي شهدت الاقتحام
الابرز قبل ايام
راينا التاثير بشكل لا يقبل التاويل في
حواره اكثر من 400 مستوطن عمليا هاجموا
هذه القريه الفلسطينيه احرقوا عشرات
المنازل ومئات السيارات
والجيش الاسرائيلي لم يفعل شيئا في مقابل
هذا المشهد عمليا هناك
رياح دفع قويه لهؤلاء
بسبب وجود
متطرفين داخل الحكومه خاصه الوزير بن جفير
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي للتذكير فقط
هو مودان بالانتماء الى تنظيم ارهابي في
اسرائيل
كاخ الممنوع قانونيا وبالتالي من تراهم في
الضفه الغربيه النواه صلبه لهؤلاء هم
ينتمون الى هذه التنظيمات هذا يؤثر كثيرا
في المقاطعه قبل قليل الفرديه بتشكيلتها
هذه تواجه اسمها داخليه كبيره احت جاجات
والمتظاهرون اليوم اشتبكوا مع الشرطه
المعارضه الاسرائيليه تشنه كذلك هجوما
لاذعا على نتنياهو وتحمله المسؤوليه هل
يمكن ان تسقط حكومه نتنياهو ام هذا مستبعد
لا حاليا هي تستند الائتلاف ثابت من 64
نائبا يمينيا ومتدينا وبالتالي لا يبدو
على الابد القريب بانها قابله للسقوط لكن
هي في مازق حقيقي قد يقود البلاد الى مازق
دستوري عمليا عندها يمكن ان تسقط نعم طيب
زياد سؤال اخير اريد ان اسالك عنها
الحقيقه مساله القانون الذي سيقرا ثلاث
مرات في الكنيست موضوع اعدام الفلسطينيين
الذين يقومون بتنفيذ عمليات في اسرائيل ما
الجديد بالنسبه لهذا القانون لهذا المشروع
طبعا هذا مشروع قانون مره في القراءه
التمهيديه يحتاج الى ثلاث قراءات يعني
يحتاج الى وقت لاقراره في الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي هو ينص على
الجواز اعدام عمليا منفذين العمليات
الفلسطينيين من قبل السلطات الاسرائيليه
قد لا يمر في نهايه المطاف ولكن فقط
للتذكير في القانون العسكري الاسرائيلي
الاعدام موجود
وميدانيا عمليا الاعدام ينفذ بدون محاكمه
في 90% من الحالات التي فيها عمليه اسمح
لي فقط انوه الى العاجل الذي ورد للتو
متظاهرون يحاصرون زوجه بنيامين نتنياهو
داخل صالون نسائي في القدس وهناك طبعا
احتجاجات كما ذكرنا مستمره ضد قانون اصلاح
القضاء في اسرائيل واليوم كان هناك
اشتباكات بين الشرطه والمتظاهرين
الاسرائيليين لا اعلم زياد الخبر اذا كان
لديه اي اضافات اي تعليق اي معلومات
اضافيه
صحيح صحيح عزيزي بنيامين نتنياهو ادلبي
بالخطاب الذي ادلى به كي يقول هذه الجمله
هو قالها في الكلمه بانهم يحاصرون زوجتي
داخل صالون يريد ان يستعطف الشارع اليمني
وان يصور المتظاهرين وكانهم يهاجمون
الشخصيه
امام منزل نتنياهو وهذه مظاهره كانت
مبرمجه من قبل المتظاهرين هذا في اطار
السجال الداخلي الاسرائيلي واطفاء بعد
دراماتيكي على ما يحدث شكرا جزيلا لك زياد
حلبي من القدس
[موسيقى]
بعد سنوات من قتال تنظيم داعش والتغلب
عليه تبقت معركه اخرى هي اكثر صعوبه وهي
مواجهه ارثه الفكريه المتطرف وبقايا
مقاتليه وافراد عائلاتها التي تتوزع في
مخيمات داخل سوريا والعراق العربيه وضمن
ترقيتها الخاصه دخلت اخطر تلك المخيمات
وهو مخيم الهول الذي تقيم فيه زوجات
مقاتلي داعش وابنائهم من العرب والاجانب
والتقت بهم ورفضت الاوضاع الامنيه فيه بعد
اكتشاف نشاط واضح بخلايا تنظيم بداخله
لن تبقى له حصون ولا مدن ولكن لا يعتقد
كثيرون هنا في شمال شرق سوريا ان تنظيم
داعش زال يقولون انه باق في مخيمات
والسجون وخلى نائمه ورحله البحث عنه لا
تبدا الا من مخيم الهول
الدخول لمخيم رهول السدعه التنقل في مركبه
مصفحه وحراسه مسلحين من قوات حمايه المخيم
وهؤلاء لا ينتشرون عاده داخل المخيم بل
يكتفون بمراقبه البوابات وتسير دوريات لكن
جوله كهذه تثير مخاوفهم من هجوم مسلح او
حتى بحجاره
[موسيقى]
53 الف شخص من 56 دوله يقطنون هنا
ويتوزعون على سته اقسام غالبيتهم من عائله
الدواعش قدمنا من الباغوز ومناطق اخرى
بدانا جولتنا من قسم المهاجرات والاسم
الذي يطلق على قسم زوجات الدواعش غير
السوريات او العراقيات واطفالهن به خيام
وسوق للملابس والخضر
من اين انت
تتحدثين قليلا
لم يكن الحديث مع الكثير منهن يسيرا رفضت
بعضهن الحديث واخريات اعاقهن اللغه
متى اتيت الى هذا المخيم
الاقتراب من اخريات كان اسهل لكن الحديث
معهن كان ينعطف سريعا الى السماته في
الدفاع عن التنظيم
[موسيقى]
اوامر من خليفه جاءتنا امير وقال انتم
لازم اجباريات
مع اخوان مجاهدين هل انتم تكرهوا هناك
ترجعوا دوله اسلاميه
[موسيقى]
لا ترغب ام محمد وهكذا تسمي نفسها بالعوده
الى مصر فهي تعتقد انما تسميها دوله
الخلافه ستعود ترغبين بالعوده الى مصر
[موسيقى]
لكن اخريات ربما يئسنا ويامن فقط بان
يعدنا لبلدانه
[موسيقى]
ترغبين فعلا بالعوده للمغرب فعلا اكيد
اليوم قبل بكره
ندمتي على ذهابك اكيد ضروري يعني لازم نحن
نرجع بلدنا ما يضلوا اوضعنا هيك يعني في
المخيم يعني انت شوفي يعني معروف الخيام
والوسخ وكل شيء يعني لازم يعني
ترحيل عائله داعش وتفكيك المخيم مسعا عبرت
عنه قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه التي طالبت
مرارا دولا باستلام رعاياها من عائله
التنظيم برايي الشخص انه اكثر من خمس سنين
او ست سنين احنا بحاجه لهم لحتى نفكك مخيم
الهول بالكامل لانه العدد كثير كبير العدد
ضخم انت عم تحكي عن 53 الف لاجئ ونازح
عندك العراقيين ما يقارب 27 الف عراقي
والسوريين اللي موجودين هن نسبتهم اكثر من
18 الف سوري اغلبيتهم هنن من مناطق سيطره
الحكومه السوريه
وعندك قسم خاص بالاجانب اللي هنن
المهاجرات او اذا بدك تخلي المخيم منهم
هنبيعها بحاجه لقرارات دوليه صارمه حتى
انت تقدري تفكي المخيم وترجعي كل هدول
لبلدانهم
مهمه صعبه اذا فيما اداره المخيم وتامينه
يبدواني اصعب
[موسيقى]
كان في حمله امنيه للقوات حمايه المخيم
داخل المخيم خلال الحمد لله الامنيه تنضبط
كميه كبيره من الاسلحه كمان تم القبض على
كثير من خلايا داعش
خطر بداوا ضحى بعد اكتشاف شبكه خنادق
وانفاق محفوره تحت الارض لتهريب السلاح
ومتطرفين وامواله
صار بن عيشوبه العربيه مخيم الهول في شمال
شرق سوريا
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اكثر من عشره
الاف كارثه خلال 33 عاما فهل عالمنا مستعد
للكوارث الطبيعيه
[موسيقى]
هل تزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا جعل
البلاده تنشغل عن الكثير من الملفات
الداخليه ابرز هذه الملفات الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقبله والتي ستجرى
في نهايه المطاف في موعدها دون اي تغيير
فرئيس التركي اعلن ان الانتخابات ستجرى في
موعدها المحدد في الرابع عشر من مايو
المقبل
واثيرت الشكوك بشان امكانيه اجراء
الانتخابات في موعدها بعد الزلزال المدمر
واثر الزلزال بشكل واضح على الحملات
الانتخابيه التي كانت تسير بشكل جيد وقت
وقوع الكارثه ونقلا مع وكاله رويترز فان
مسؤولا تركيا قال ان الكارثه خلقت صعوبات
جامه امام اجراء الانتخابات في موعلها
سيما على المستوى اللوجستي وكانت المناطق
التي ضربها الزلزال تضم حوالي ثمانيه
ملايين ناخب مسجل اي ما يعادل 14% من
الناخبين المتوقع ان يبث المجلس الاعلى
للانتخابات في تركيا في كيفيه اجراء
الاقتراع في تلك الولايات او ما اذا كان
يمكن اجراء الاقتراع هناك من الاساس
ولا يبدو واضحا مدى تاثير الزلزال على
حموض اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
فهناك بعض الانتقادات التي وجهت اليه من
المعارضه بسبب بطء وتيره استجابه الحكومه
عقب حدوث الزلزال الى جانب اكتشاف سوء
البنيه التحتيه ووجود حالات غش كثيره في
عمليات البناء
ما ادى الى فتح تحقيق واعتقال العديد من
المقاولين واصحاب الشركات البناء اما
مؤيدوا اردوغان فيرون ان الانطلاقه
السريعه لجهود اعاده البناء ودعم
المتضررين من شانه ان يرفع من اسهم الرئيس
التركي في الانتخابات القادمه
[موسيقى]
ترقب تعيشها مدينه اسطنبول بعد تداول
العديد من الشائعات التي تشير الى امكانيه
حدوث زلزال قوي في اكبر المدن التركيه
بلديه اسطنبول اخذت الموضوع على محمل الجد
من خلال اعلان رئيسها اكرم عن خطه شامله
لمواجهه خطر الزلازل وهذا الزلزال المتوقع
بالتحديد في مدينه اسطنبول وتاتي الخطه
وسط توقع الجهات الرسميه ومختصنا في
الزلزال في الزلازل عفوا بان مدينه
اسطنبول معرضه بحكم موقعها لخطر حدوث
زلزال كبير بقوه تتجاوز
7.5 درجه على مقياس ريختر وتقدر الجهات
المختصه في تركيا ان عشرات الالاف من
المباني في مدينه اسطنبول معرضه للانهيار
الكامل حال وقوع زلزال بهذه القوه
وخطر الزلزال تحول الى ورقه ضغط سياسي بين
يدي المعارضه التي تتهم الحكومه بالفشل في
التعامل مع ازمه الزلزال جنوب البلاد في
ايامه الاولى كما تقول المعارضه ان
الحكومه فاشله ايضا في امتحان الرقابه على
اشغال البناء مضيفه ان الحزب الحاكم لم
يتخذ اي اجراءات منذ تسلمه الحكم قبل نحو
20 عاما لمواجهه خطر الزلازل خاصه في
مدينه كاسطنبول التي يعيش فيها نحو 20
مليون نسمه
معنى من اسطنبول دكتور بكير اتجان مدير
معهد اسطنبول للفكر الدكتور بكير اهلا بك
معنا لماذا تصر السلطات التركيه على اجراء
الانتخابات في موعدها رغم ان هناك عشر
ولايات متضرره عدد كبير من سكانها فروا من
تلك المناطق
وطبعا ان تبعات الزلزال لم تنحصر بعد
وهناك تخوف من زلزال جديده او حاله الخوف
ما تزال موجوده على الاقل فلماذا تصير
السلطات التركيه على اجراء الانتخابات في
موعدها
مساء الخير تحياتي لكم
نعم للاسف الشديد هناك ما زالت تركيا
تعاني وسوف تعاني في الايام او في الاشهر
القادمه ايضا لان الزلزال تهدد جميع
انحاء تركيا وليست فقط الشمال او الجنوب
او الشرق او الغرب وليست فقط كما قلتم في
تقريركم قبل قليل بما في اسطنبول والمدن
الاخرى ولكن اذا اخذنا بين الاعتبار اذا
غير ممكن اذا ان نذهب لا الى انتخابات ولا
الى اي شيء لذلك لابد على تركيا ان تاخذ
بين الاعتبار طبيعي هذه الخواطر ولكن في
نفس الوقت
ان تنجز المشاريع التي ان كانت هذه
انتخابيه او مباني او حكوميه مهما كانت
الاسباب نعم والدليل على ذلك يعني هنا
للانتخابات سبعين يوما اعتبارا غدا 70 يوم
بالضبط هذه فتره طويله يعني فتره طويله
تستطيع الحكومه وحتى المشاكل 70 يوما في
هذه ولكن المعارضه التركيه
معقوله نسبيا كما تفضلت ولكن بالنظر الى
حجم الكارثه قد تبدو قصيره نوعا ما خاصه
في ظل الانتقادات الشديده من المعارضه
التركيه
للرئيس والحزب الحاكم بانه فشل في التعاطي
مع زلزال وبان خاصه مع اكتشاف مسائل الغش
في يعني معايير البناء
وكل ما تبع ذلك كذلك من انتقادات
يعني اذا اخذنا بالاعتبار ما تدعيه
المعارضه نقول نعم لهم الحق ولكن اذا
اخذنا بان الاعتبار ما تقوله الجهه الاخرى
الحكومه وانصارها ايضا نقول لهم الحق
لماذا لماذا لان كما اشرت قبل قليل تركيا
يعني الدوله
تحيطها الزلازل وتاريخيا منطقه الزلزاليه
منذ القديم وما زالت وحصلت فيها زلازل قبل
اشهر عده مدن يعني ليست الاولى من نواحيها
ولكن النقطه هامه لابد ذكرها عفوا هذه
النقطه مهمه اريد ان اذكرها هنا المعارضه
كانت ضد فكره تحديث المباني وخاصه في
مدينه انطاكيا اسكندرون
ومراش المدن التي حصلت فيها الزلزال حصريا
لماذا لماذا لانها تدعي كانت بان هذه
المدن في حال حصل فيها هذا التح المباني
واشياء اخرى من هذا النوع
فكانت هذه المناطق تعتبر المعارضه بانها
خلالها فاذا حصل التحديث وخاصه من طرف
الحكومه فهذه تتحول تدريجيا الى انصار
الحكومه ولذلك كانت تعارض بالشده حتى
اسطنبول تعرض عليها بشده على التحديث يعني
من تعرض ليست الاهالي بينما الحكومه تعطي
على سبيل المثال انا اقول لنفسي لدي مكان
في مدينه اسطنبول فرجعت الحكومه لكي
تعطيني قروض فاعطتني ليست قروض قالت لي
انت ثلاث سنين تحتاج لتجديد هذا المكان
فتحتاج اذا
مبالغ لهذه اعطتني المبالغ مقدما وانا قمت
باللازم وما زالت لن تدعي بعد لذلك
الحكومه تشجع وتعطي ان كانت نقدي او حتى
دعم من اطراف اخرى ايضا ولكن للاسف
المعارضه الى الان تعارض ولكن تقترح بعض
الامور والتي هي تطبيقها صعب الان وفي
المستقبل عفوا مباشره من اسطنبول شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
وزلزال تركيا المدمر فتح النقاشه من جديد
حول الكوارث الطبيعيه التي باتت تشكل مصدر
تهديد حقيقي للبشريه بشكل عام بهذا الخصوص
اكدت ممثله الخاصه للامم المتحده للحد من
المخاطر مامي ميزوروتو ان التحديات
المتعدده في السنوات الثلاث الماضيه ابرزت
الحاجه لتحسن او تحسين التاهب للكوارث
المقبله وكشفت ميزوتوري ان العالم اضحى
الان بحاجه الى تعزيز البنى التحتيه
والنظم البيئيه بدلا من اعاده بنائها لاحق
وتشير العديد من التقارير العلميه الى ان
العالم ليس مستعدا على نحو كاف لمواجهه
الكوارث الطبيعيه فغالبا ما تتحرك
الحكومات بعد وقوع الكوارث ودعا مركز
الدراسات الدوليه للكوارث الطبيعيه الى
تعميم انظمه الانذار المبكر مشيرا الى ان
التحذير من حدوث عاصفه قبل 24 ساعه مثلا
قد يقلل الضرر بنسبه 30% ومنذ العام تسعين
اثرت الكوارث الطبيعيه المختلفه على اكثر
من سته مليارات شخص في العالم وفقا
لبيانات مكتب الامم المتحده للحد من مخاطر
الكوارث وتاتي على راس القائمه الفيضانات
والعواصف التي اشتدت بفعل تغير المناخ
وتمثل 42% من اجمالي الكوارث
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه عطل يتسبب
بانقطاع خدمات تويتر عن الاف المستخدمين
[موسيقى]
لا تعض اليد التي تطعمك بهذه الكلمات
هاجمت الصين اغلى رجل في العالم الامريكي
ايلون ماسك الرجل الذي داب على ابداء
ارائه السياسيه بشكل صريح اثار حفيظه
الصين من خلال حديثه عن مصدر نشاه فيروس
كورونا فكين حذرت ماسك من مشاركه
المنشورات التي تروج لنظريه تسرب فيروس
كورونا من مختبرهان في الصين
تحذير المباشر اذا وشديد اللهجه لكنه لم
ياتي على لسان احد المسؤولين الصينيين
فالتحذير نشر على صحيفه جلوبال تايمز
الحكوميه وكان الكاتب يرد على تعليق ماسك
على استنتاج وزاره الطاقه الامريكيه بان
فيروس كوبيت 19 نشا في مختبر في وهران
الصينيه تحذير الصحيفه حمله بين سطور
حمله بين السطور بين السطور هذا المقال
اذا تلويحا بامكانيه الاضرار بمصالح ماسك
في الصين سيما شركته للسيارات الكهربائيه
تسلا وتملك شركه تسلا مصنعا في شنغهاي
الصينيه كما ان الصين هي ثاني اكبر سوق
للشركه
انا من باريس دكتور حسان القبه الباحث في
الاقتصاد السياسي دكتور اهلا بك معنا لا
تعض اليد التي تطعمك هل حقا الصين هي اليد
التي تطعم الى الماسك وهو بالمناسبه عاده
الى قائمه المرتبه الاولى كاغنى رجل في
العالم قبل ايام
نعم هكذا
يبدو
احتجاجا على غرد به ماسك ماسك ملك تويتر
وما ادراك ما تويتر يعني ملك تويتر ويغرد
بكثافه يغرد بكثافه يبدو ان الجانب الصيني
مربى منزعج لكن عوده هذا السجال السجال
الفيروس الصيني امريكي امريكي صيني موقع
ماسك ربما كذلك من من ما يحدث في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بين الجمهورين
والديمقراطيين ربما صفاف لنظريه
ماسك بالنسبه اليه الصين سوق مهمه جدا
ولكن ليست الوحيده ولكن كرجل الاعمال وكان
لديه مصنع لتسلا كبير جدا في شنغهاي كما
ذكرنا والصين يعني من اهم اسواق السيارات
الكهربائيه وبالتحديد سياره تيسلا طيب
دكتور لماذا
ذهب ايلون ماسك للحديث على موضوع السياسه
والحديث على
نشات فيروس كورونا وتسربه من مختبر في
وهران وهو يعلم جيدا انه لديه مصالح كبيره
مع الصين
نعم هو من المفروض من لديه مصالح عديده
يتحاشى مثل هذه المواضيع ولكن ماسك كما
قلنا نشط جدا على موقع تويتر وكذلك ربما
في اشاره في هذه الحرب التجاريه القائمه
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من جهه
والصين من جهه اخرى مع دخول بايدن قال سوف
تتواصل الحرب ولكن سوف تبقى في اطر اخرى
ليست بنفس الطريقه التي يعني مارسها في
وقت من الاوقات ولكن ربما هي نصره نعرف ان
ماسك لما اشترى تويتر قال ربما سوف نسمح
بفتح حسابات تروم المغلقه على تويتر
بالنسبه للصين الصين الصين ليست فقط سوق
مهمه ومصنع كذلك الصين اليوم اليوم
بالنسبه للبطاريات
الالكترونيه التي تعمل بها السيارات
الكهربائيه كذلك تتحول على ممكن قص كبير
من هذه السوق العالميه وربما حتى هي مزود
لذلك هناك يعني ممكن تحذير خفيف علما ان
قانون الاستثمار الصيني قانون وحتى
القوانين في الصين تضمن ممكن المستثمرين
الاجانب لان الصين عندما قبل ان تخرج
وتكون هي من الدول الرائده في الاستثمار
الاجنبي في الخارج عملت منذ التسعينات على
استقطاب رجال الاعمال واليوم حتى مشكل مع
السلطات الصينيه لرجل اعمال مثل ايلون
ماسك لن يشجع كذلك يعني الموضوع لديه
تجاذبات عديده وسوف يطول ولكن التوقيت
ربما نقف على التوقيت لماذا في هذا
التوقيت بالذات العالم بدا ينسى مسله
الفيروس ممكن الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
اخذت ممكن الاهتمام الاكبر العالم ولكن
كانه يعود بنا لمثله يعني نهايه 2019
عندما ظهر في وهران نتذكر جيدا اخر 19 ثم
انتشر في كل العالم وبدا هذا السجل لماذا
هذا التوقيت بالذات ربما ربما حقيقه نقطه
استفهام كوبرا ولكن العالم اليوم
الرهان العالمي اليوم دعني اقول انه
رهان اقتصادي بحث راينا حتى العديد من
الدول
العالميه والقوه الاقليميه تجنب كل
المشاكل السياسه تحاول ان تكون سياسه سفر
مشاكل والتركيز كل التركيز على الناحيه
الاقتصاديه لان التحديات الاقتصاديه
العالميه كبيره في هذه المرحله حتى تحديات
المناخ وحتى تحديات المناخ والعالم يريد
هذا التحول
وتعليقا يعني الحقيقه انت محق فيما ذهبت
اليه يعني نسينا تماما انه كان هناك
كورونا في ضوء الاحداث التي توالت بعد بعد
الوباء شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور حسن القبي من
باريس
[موسيقى]
مجموعه ام بي سي بان مسلسل معاويه ما زال
قيد التحضير واكدت ان موعد عرضه سيتم
تحديده لاحقا ونفت المجموعه صدور اي
بيانات او كتب رسميه منها وشددت ام بي سي
على ان البيانات المتعلقه بمجموعتها تصدر
رسميا عنها وتوزع عبر مكتبها الاعلامي من
مقرها الرئيسي وان المصدر الوحيد الموثوق
للمعلومات المتعلقه بانتاجاتها وعروضها
وجداولها هو الشاشات ومنصاتها وصفحاتها
الرسميه فقط
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز
العناوين
بعد ان اقتربت اوكرانيا تشن هجوما على
القرم وروسيا تشدد الرقابه على الحدود
والحركه الجويه
قائد القياده المركزيه للجيش الاسرائيلي
يعترف بان عنف المستوطنين في بلده حواره
كان مجزره المنظمه
العربيه في مخيم الهول ترصد الاوضاع
الامنيه فيه بعد اكتشاف نشاط واضح لخلايا
التنظيم بداخله
لا تعض اليد التي تطعمك بهذه الكلمات
الصين تهاجم الى الماسك وتهدده بتسلا
والسبب تغريدات حول اصل كورونا
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
يبقى على العربيه على مواقع التواصل
واعود والقاكم بعد قليل في اللقاء
[موسيقى]